what's up everyone welcome back to the
collider Studio presented by Saratoga
Spring Water we've got another Sundance
2023 interview for you with the team
behind to live and die and live
congratulations on your movie yay thank
you awesome you're probably getting this
a lot today but I need you to do the
honors and give a synopsis of your movie
because we know what it is but a lot of
people out there who can't be at
Sundance this year do not okay
um to live and I live a story about
Muhammad who uh comes home to bury his
recently deceased stepfather
um and is assigned with completing all
these tasks to settle his estate and
such
um
but he may be finished by his addiction
and issues before he finishes the task I
got it right that's impressive about
time I've been fumbling along that
synopsis for days now just like it's
about a guy who
I'm glad all that practice paid off here
but I'm glad you got all the practice
because that means you are spreading the
love for your movie as you should be at
this Festival so this industry comes
with a lot of roadblocks and I was
reading that the film was rejected from
last year's festival and it's a it's a
pretty big deal to be able to to
overcome that and Forge forward and not
get dejected so what was it like
processing that and figuring out what
you needed to do to make sure your movie
got seen but still adhere to your
original Vision wow you read up on this
huh oh I did I did so
um
one thing I think you learn or I hope
you learn in this business is patience
you know
um
I meet people who come to LA or New York
or something all right I got two years
if I don't blow up in two years if I
don't blow up is I'm gonna I'm like all
right bro I'll talk to you in in a few
um
um but you look at the landscape and and
when they when they initially were like
look it's it's not ready you need a lot
more time with this movie
um
in retrospect they were right
um we sent a very long cut in it was not
nearly what it is
um and to be honest in perspective like
things that become important priorities
that my family was a big priority at
that time and if I'm trying to complete
this movie last winter
uh to to make the deadlines for Sundance
I don't get to spend like that real like
committed time with the family that I
got to spend
um and so you know I knew I had to go
back at it and that's what
re resubmitting allowed me to do later
another question that's going to reveal
how much research I did you move you
moved back to Detroit yeah that can be a
scary thing in this industry to move
away from the Hub from Hollywood or New
York and still feel like you have a
chance to make it in this business so
for anyone out there who needs to
prioritize themselves but still want to
have a foot in this world what would you
tell them how did it work for you and
how could it work for them
so I can't answer the second part of
that question because I don't everyone's
journey is so different
everyone you talk to who has gained any
ground in this industry has a completely
different story for the most part
so I don't know but maybe my story can
give some insight
for me it was it was
it was the pandemic so we are learning
that a lot of things could be virtual
it was me watching my son becoming a
pandemic baby who only understood his
parents to be home and
to be inside right realizing we have all
this family back home that he could be
around and when it came to it that
became the most important thing and you
know I I'm I'm a writer and director
um and I can make stuff
so I can make stuff anywhere
and I can write anywhere
I if I need to go to La for meetings I
will do that I'll come there once a
month
um that's fine
um and for anyone
else trying to break in or whatever I
think you know you do great work the
work speaks you know
could not agree more with that Corey I
want to come your way because I know
you've worked with uh custom before yes
what is something about his approach to
the work that has stayed consistent from
film to film but what is something he
accomplished on this one that made even
you go like damn I can't believe you're
capable of that now
he dare he dared costume is a brother of
mine but he dared to be great you know
he uh he said I'm taking this back home
to the D you know shout out to Detroit
and he just believed in it you know he
loves Detroit this guy breathed sleep
seats Detroit so it's just like I knew
that Detroit had something to offer like
cinematically and the texture of Detroit
and I knew costume was going to capture
all of those things and he's just so
passionate when he's like saying this is
going to work you know sometimes I'm
grabbing the camera I'm gonna be doing
everything but Corey we got we got
something special and it was on the page
so that's how I knew when when I when I
hear the passion he just has to call me
and I would I would always be there
um for him and we worked you know we did
Destin before but this is uh he takes it
a step further and um amen Sky
um you know Miriam his sister everybody
is amazing in this film and uh hopefully
I want to ask her one day I'm going for
the nomination speak it into existence I
believe in the power of manifestation
yes yes and and that's what I believe
you say what you get so if you say it
enough you're going to get it and you
can do anything on God's green earth and
I do believe that I moved to LA with
seventy dollars true story and look at
me now I'm at Sundance you know share
that belief I like that with gold teeth
in my mouth
for my supporting Ensemble I'm leaving
you out you have a Powerhouse
for my supporting Ensemble it is hard
enough to give a full picture of a lead
character's life but then you only get
so much screen time to work with and you
need to be able to support the lead
character but also make your character
feel like they have history and that
they're whole so can you each tell me
something you came up with for your
character that we don't necessarily see
on screen or hear about via dialogue but
you thought about it and we can now feel
it influencing your performance and
making it whole
question
no you go first Marion you ain't said
nothing that's married yeah you go you
go I'll just say it was very easy for me
to connect with with amen with Muhammad
because it was just so real there was a
lot that happened off screen including
you know him being around our real
family a lot in Detroit with my mother
was doing the catering for the film she
was around every single day
like we were all there and creating real
connections eating together I remember
um Eamon told me he said you know
because I don't like plantains I don't
like anything that's like banana related
smell nothing he's like you know just
taste this plant and I'm like okay and
it was really good I'm like he's right
so things like that happen that just
authentically made him feel like a
brother you know so it was just natural
I love that
have a fit it to you yeah for me
um
playing the role of Asia
I pretty much hijacked the character to
therapeutically try and heal myself from
Life Experiences you know I'm an adult
woman with a lot of adult experiences
and I didn't necessarily look at it or
deal with it I would avoid it and you
would see that even in Asia's character
and the commonalities that she shared
with Muhammad was the avoidance of grief
and acceptance in the inevitable
and being able to play Asia with
Muhammad was just so so easy with Eamon
because
Eamon just gave me so much permission to
be present and Unleash the Beast inside
you know because as actors we can have
an idea of what we want to do
but when you realize your scene partner
is not watching you perform your same
partner is in it with you Eamon is in it
with him and challenges you you know
what I mean he's not waiting for his
next line you know he's feeling it as
you go which makes you have to feel it
as he goes and and you just yeah you
just say so present in the moment and
that's what I did with with Asia was
just to stay as grounded as humanly
possible but also feel everything that I
was feeling
Corey pressure's on can you follow those
two answers well I'm Gonna Be Quick my
thing is out you know the characters
short and sweet but it's it's a pivotal
character in Muhammad's life you know I
feel like he could show I show
vulnerability of every what every black
man goes through in this country and
across the world you know and even
though we we're coming from like the
inner city Detroit he can still say you
know we still feel as human beings that
you're scared you know the police you
know no matter what we're all scared of
the police when especially a black man
at four or five in the morning you get
out hands up you know there's no cameras
out there really it's just you and the
police so it's kind of like to show that
moment that real moment of what we deal
with in society today and to just tell
them you know I'm scared for my life you
know it's like he spoke for every black
man in the world at that moment so I
love the vulnerability of my character
for real
all right Eamon you're up you're your
performance my God Muhammad's got a lot
on his plate in this movie of everything
he's going through of everything he's
trying to deal with which specific
element of that character did you think
would be most challenging and then
ultimately was that the most challenging
or did something else about him captured
by surprise
I initially thought that the most
challenging thing would be
the functioning addiction of it all
um
because
he's dealing with an anxiety of burying
his stepfather
and he's already a functioning addict
so how would I approach
his behavior
his highs and lows
in the context of grief
the death of someone that is pivotal
part of the foundation of who this man
is he's losing and he has to bury him so
quickly because of his culture that's
what I initially thought would be the
most challenging
um aspect of filming and of Muhammad
would actually became the hardest thing
is
the consistency of going through
a 20-some day shoot
with that was as taxing emotionally as
it was physically
and
to not go to sleep at night because
Muhammad just wouldn't sleep at night
and turn around
and give you know hopefully a 12-hour
day
um performance hopefully right but that
was but that grind the the just the
physical toll it took me a while coming
back to uh to decompress and and uh
and to shake Muhammad you know
when you're playing a character who's
dealing with so much and has some maybe
knee-jerk reactions to things expresses
warmth and loves to his family I could
go on and on listing things do you have
to come up with I guess an anchor or
kind of a Guiding Light for the
character so that no matter what
headspace he's in you always know every
decision and choice he makes is based in
some sort of consistent truth
yeah I mean I have to do that just for
me personally but my cast I have a
phenomenal cast here and they're they're
they're so giving that I could depend on
the family for a certain anchor of
support I could depend on the Muslim
faith and that I would actually have to
learn
while I was filming I could look at sky
I could look at Corey Amari I could look
at Omar I could look at Miriam and in
those eyes I realize that this is a
living breathing production and this is
a story to tell of that costs them so
wonderfully wrote that I could live in
this I can I can I don't have to make up
anything here
the words will follow just follow the
story and be vulnerable enough thank you
for the opportunity to be vulnerable
vulnerable to be human to have this you
know it's the most vulnerable I've I've
ever been and it's it's really hard
watching it because it's a vulnerability
of two years ago and I have a
vulnerability of just talking right now
so it is it's an honor it's a privilege
to uh create art like this and that's
what I was you know that's what really
at the end of the day meant the most to
me
full answer and I want to say too that
we felt your vulnerability and it was
hard for us to watch too just as an
audience because we all felt that
vulnerability through your performance
yeah it's like this movie has a spirit
like there's a spirit with the movie
it's just kind of like the Underdog
Story and it's just like everybody
costumes and actors dream like every
actor wants to be in the film a costume
I said it earlier like it's kind of like
he grabs the camera and he just walks
into the neighborhood
and we just get behind it and jump in
the camera like yeah let's just say that
too that's a dream go ahead see how like
the movie has like some huge celebrity
right like we'll say we'll just say I
don't know Denzel Washington
Detroit was like a Denzel Washington
right it was a character in the film yes
and
I've never seen a filmmaker have access
the way that he does like he has a
Denzel in the movie which is Detroit the
man got into the airport in August of
2021 everybody had on mass right so we
didn't have to get anything you know all
the way to the gate he got to the
cameras yes
with their mask off yes yes
how did you do that they gave them 15
minutes to do it 15. y'all need to wrap
it up or I'm gonna lose my job
Detroit just lended the city to costume
I've never seen anyone have that kind of
connection to so many human beings in a
city in my entire experience in this
industry and it's because of who he is
and when he's already done 100 for
Detroit in his film making history yeah
and because of that people who are from
Detroit like they're going to recognize
that rock scene they're gonna know
exactly where that was they know every
bridge everything they're going to
recognize those things and it makes it
more authentic and I just to say with
all this too I gotta say thank you to to
my cast for trusting because you didn't
know all that before you came to Detroit
you know yeah I didn't know what I was
hopping on the plane I got on the plane
I didn't know Corey knew because he'd
been out there before and he's been on a
ride with me before but I just want to
say bro like you you
to show up as an actor and you don't
know what you you don't know what you're
you know what's today going to be like
this is an independent film in Detroit
and to see your filmmaker
with the camera on his back
I tell I tell custom this all the time
I've never shot a film where the the man
carried the film on his literal back he
no massages we didn't have any time off
this man had the actual rig on his back
so as I'm going through and and it's a
tough shoot and it's a lot of walking
there's a it's just a physical shoot as
well and it was hot watching this man
with the you know I can't take off I'm
looking at him he's strapping this you
know what was it a Steadicam it was the
the um the Armor Man the Armor man yeah
to hold up the Ronin yeah with the
and it shows and it shows in the film
the quality is just more rich and gritty
because of that yeah it's incredible I
feel like when when you're casting your
next movie you just you clip this out
and you send it to everyone you want to
work with and be like look what I can
give you I could talk about your movie
all day long I'm not allowed to I have
to let you guys go okay huge huge huge
congratulations thank you thank you
thank you congratulations to you you
know we go way back and I'm so proud of
you oh that's amazing
I'm proud of you we're celebrating your
movie and everybody out there should
know about I'm gonna say it again
congratulations to everybody out there
keep an eye out for to live and die and
live also stay tuned we'll have more
interviews from Sundance 2023 for you
very soon